we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192
david p
um here is a caller
thrilled that madison cothorn lost i
have to tell you i also am thrilled
about it
hey david it's dylan from north carolina
i'm just letting you know that i love
the show baby you do a great job you do
some great coverage yes sir yes sir and
also
uh i really just want to say that i'd
like to rejoice in the fact that madison
hawthorne is no longer in the
[ __ ] house get that [ __ ] out of
here baby love you david take care thank
you so much for the call yeah it is i
mean listen we
i get it the guy who beat madison
cawthorne is almost certainly going to
be the winner in that district
and it will stay with a republican it's
not like madison cawthorne is being
replaced with a reasonable democrat or a
progressive
but because cawthorne is emblematic of
the debasement of american politics
where a completely incompetent clown
with no no business being involved in
politics
wins thanks to the combination of riding
trump's coattails and the megawave of
the 2020 well yeah all this different
stuff
it is still a good thing to see him lose
and see him removed we'll then have to
you know deal with the fact that the guy
who replaces him will probably be 80 as
bad
uh but it's okay to be happy about it
i'm happy madison cawthorne lost he had
no business being there and
unfortunately i don't know that we're
going to be as successful in making some
of some of these other maga people uh
one-term members of congress we're going
to try don't get me wrong we're going to
try
but i don't know that it will be
successful let's just be happy that he
lost at least for the next day
we are going to talk on the bonus show
today uh and this is that same bonus
show that alex jones has been talking
about the bonus show where you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad yeah
that's the one i'm talking about a
lawsuit is now seeking more than two
million dollars in damages
from the fake republican electors in
wisconsin this would be
beautiful
beautiful if it succeeded number two the
fda is announcing some plans to ease the
shortage of baby formula which is
becoming an area of major concern
parents just worried am i going to have
the formula to feed my kid
and thirdly a judge strikes down
tennessee's transgender bathroom sign
law
this is this is a genuinely interesting
case and it has to do with a lot of
different things going on at the federal
level and at the state level and
elsewhere so we're going to talk about
that on today's bonus show as well if
you want to get access to the bonus show
today
very easy sign up at joinpakman.com you
can use the coupon code obama to get a
discount if you'd rather get the big
discount on memorial day fine fine with
me it's only 12 days away
get on my newsletter at davidpakman.com
and then monday morning monday memorial
day you'll get an email in which i will
tell you how to take advantage of this
great membership discount so no no shame
in waiting until memorial day we will
see you on the bonus show or otherwise
we'll be back tomorrow with a brand new
show